実家デーィス
あ違った
実家でーぃす!
はい、こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
いま実家に帰っております
もう
全員集結
今下で、皆ご飯食べてるんですけどー
やっぱねー
家だと動画撮りづらいっすねー
家族がいると気使っちゃうんで
なかなかここ動画撮れないんで、今日はちょっと
ンァ痛待って
刺さった×２
ああああああ
動画が撮りずらい環境下におかれてるんですけども
なんかね、やっぱ実家ていうのは面白いもので
僕がいつも住んでいる家にはない、何かがあったりするんですよね
なんかいろんなぬいぐるみが
ありがてぇことに
ちょっと僕の部屋が物置に使われてて
ちょっと環境が変わったりしてるんですけども
まあ
11月後半
もうすぐ
受験の季節ですね
はいというわけでなんかやっぱりね
超勉強して大学で静岡に行ったんで
なんか実家に来るとやっぱりちょっと勉強のこと
なんかいろいろ見てると、なんかいろんなもんが出てきたんで
ちょっとそれを紹介しようかなと思います
ぜひ
なんかみんなの勉強のモチベーションになればいいな、と思っているので
今日はちょっと
ためになる
いい動画になるかもしれません
とりあえずあのー
まあ
勉強つってもね
小学校まあまあ
バカ
中学校
バカすぎて
中二の英語のテストで確か赤点取って
そこからちょっと塾に入れさせられました
入れさせられたというか僕から言ったのかな
ちょっとやばいということで
公文に入れさせてもらいました
でもほんとに英語が全くできなかったから
なんか英語の勉強を超させられまくって
で、そのまま中三まで勉強したら結構いい線行って
そのままなんか普通科の高校に行ったんですけど
あーなんかこう言うね
ちょっと懐かしい
マジで懐かしい
こういうね公文のプリントをずっとやってたわけですよ
分詞構文
WhenIenteredtheroom,Isawanicepicture.（私が部屋に入った時私は素敵な絵を見ました。）
全然△とかついてますけど
何が間違ってんだこれ
すげえもう分詞構文がなにかもわかんないわ
ハッハ
全部忘れちゃった
という感じで公文のプリントをめちゃくちゃやってたんだよな確か
惜しいね
×と△がついてます
チッ
まあ結局ですね
人はどこかで変わらないと
上に進めないんで
バカだった僕は
何をすればいいかわかんなかったんで
何をすればいいかちゃんと書いてある公文のプリントで勉強しまくったのが
まあちゃんと勉強というものに取り組んだスタートでしたね
あとこういうプリントなんですけど
ほらわかんない単語にもう色まで塗っちゃって
どんだけ俺やる気あるんだよっていう
あーちゃんと書いてありますね
わかんない単語にはちゃんと線を塗って、覚えようとしていたみたいです
あーもうでも×だらけ
全然合ってないんですけどね
まあ人は間違って学習して覚えていく人間なので
まあこうやって僕も、間違いまくりながら勉強してたわけですよ
公文で
ガチャ×2
はぁはぁはぁ
撮りづらいよ
人がいると撮りづらいよ
やだぁ恥ずかしい
あ〇がついてます
ありがてぇ
という感じでひたすら公文のプリントをやりまくってたら
気づいたら英語が得意になってたよっていうお話です
でもう一つ僕～あの～
たぶん皆さん僕の動画を見てて気づいたと思うんですけど
僕日本語がとても下手で
日本語がよくわかんない
ふっｗ
あの国語が苦手でしたね
なんか小説とか全然もう意味わかんない
だってそんなの
読む人によってとらえ方って様々じゃん
て思ってたんです
簡単な文を
もうほんとにひたすらやりまくりました
もう%&$#'=~\だいぶやってますよ僕ちらもこっこう
ほんとにマジ超やってるじゃん俺
基本百点じゃん
そりゃそうだわ
中学校の問題を、僕は高校の時一生懸命やりまくって
ちょっと日本語の勉強をした訳ですよ
どう思いますかみたいな問題の時にほら
もう少し長く
もう一個ももう少し長く
なんか俺英語が苦手というより
結局
国語が一番苦手だったなぁ
ということに気づきましたねぇ
ほらちゃんとね
こーやって
漢字の練習とかも
高校の時ですよ多分これ
高校の時に漢字練習とかしまくって
中学校の
滅茶苦茶プリントをこなしまくる日々が
まぁ高校の初期にありました
なんかこれホントに多分ね
あたし馬鹿です僕馬鹿です
みたいな人いると思うんですけど
その人と同じレベル位
いやもっと下かもしんない
結構馬鹿なんですよ
今もなんですけどね
勉強苦手な人って
何したらいいかわかんないって言うのが一番あると思うんで
取り合えず僕は公文で与えられたプリントをただただこなすという
ロボットに
進化しました
基礎的なものが何か付いてきたのか分からないんですけど
大学受験に挑んだ時にぃ
なんかねぇ勉強って頑張れば伸びるだろうって思うんですけど
まそうもいかない時も
たまにありまして
どんだけ勉強しても
やってない分野とかがあると
絶対分かんないじゃないですか
その問題が出たとき
なんで自分がどこの勉強をやってるかっていうのを
分かりやすくするように
人生で初めて
これか多分これこれこれ
これですこれですあぁこれですねぇ
どっかでダウンロードしたのかなぁ
ちょっと見てみますか
あのーうわやべぇなにこれ
理科の解答用紙だ
物理だ物理の問題用紙だ
７３点でした１００点中
まぁまぁやないかい
マジで懐かしいなこれ
学習計画表というものを作っておりました
使う教材とかを書いたり
一か月の学習時間がどんぐらいになるかとか
すげぇ本試験まであと何日か書けるとこだったり
午前と午後で何するかとかぁ
一日の最後に出来たかどうかとか
１１月だったら１１月で
何を勉強するかを全て書いていました
まぁ簡単に午前午後夜って分けて
何するかっていうね
ちょっと見てみると
なんか文で書いてあるのは
なにしてたんだろう
ちょっと俺ざっくり過ぎん
国語だな
さっきの公文のやつかもしんねぇな
多分あの公文の国語のプリントをやってたんだと思います
日本語が下手過ぎたんで
で午後は
英単語やって化学のⅠ
何ページまでやるかとか書いて
じゃあ物理６ページやりますっていう
で夜はただ予習しますっていって
公文行ったり行って何するか数Ⅲしたり
物理何ページやるか
あと10回俺10回もやってたのキモ
まあけどね10回やんないと頭に入んないタイプだったんで
こういう感じでまあ模試の日もあれば代々木ゼミの日もありますと
推薦帰宅って書いてあるね
てか一か月で135時間も勉強してたんだね
何時間勉強しましたっていうより
その日に何々が終わりましたみたいなちゃんと計画立てて試験の日まで
全部できるかどうかっていうのを
計算立ててやってましたねいつから始めたんだろう
11日だ10月の11日から
スケジュール立てて勉強してたんだ
ほら何するかちゃんと書いてあったよ
マジでわかりやすいんすよね
馬鹿な僕でも
とても分かりやすかったです
これもたぶんねちゃんとやってた気がします
毎日勉強してたな12月もやって
これでセンター試験まで残り15日なんですよね
これセンタープレテストとか書いてある
超緊張してたんだろうなー
やべ懐かしくてなんか緊張するな
センター試験がありました1日目
スゲーなこれ
直前のこれなんかセンター試験の、英語やったんですけど
なんかこれ200点中たしか192点とれたんで
めっちゃテンション上がったんですけど当日大失敗しました。。。
過信したね、自分の力を
計画立てって大事っすよね
母）まあね、予定しないとね
そうですよね、、
ありがとうございました
蕁麻疹はできてたね
蕁麻疹できました、、勉強しすぎで
僕もうほんとバカだったんで、全然天才、、、、
いや、天才だけどねｗｗ
天才だけど～、勉強に関してはちょっとパワーがなかったんで
努力というか気合いでカバーしていくしかないかなと思ったんで
ひたすら時間をかけてやってました
高３の人とかセンター試験近いと思うし
何やっていいかわかんなかったんですけど、
僕は今見た通り
何月からやったっけ、、１０月の11日かｗ
いやもう間に合わねぇや
ごめんなさい、間に合わないです
いや！そこであきらめちゃダメなんです
僕はちゃんと計算立てて勉強したのが10月からで
そっから間に合わせてセンター試験のぞんだので
１１月から始めても僕は遅くないと思ってますし
始めるんだったらがむしゃらにやるんじゃなくて、計算たてて
その日の午前中何をするか、午後何をするか
その日の夜何をするか
もう全部書きゃいいんすよ
書いてその通りやれば必ず
それが実現するんで
まぁ僕計算たてたりするのが超嫌い、大嫌いなんですけど
受験の時は計画たててやって
満足はいってないですけど
結果はでたのかな？って思ってます
ただただ勉強することも大事だと思うんですけど
予定を立ててスケジュールを立てて、確実にこなして
見える目標に向かっていくのがコツかなって思います
そんな頭良くないですけど、
バカなりの考えで、頑張った受験勉強でした
高３は今すごい焦る時期だと思うんで
焦らず着実に勉強頑張っていってください
めっちゃいい動画じゃん！